- Oh my god, that's beautiful!
- Hi!
(audience cheering)
- Oh come on, thank you.
- I love the colors!
I was like, you wear your colors today.
- Have we draped ourselves?
- I know, we've draped ourselves.
- This is the part where you sit down
and you're like, and drape.
- And drape.
So wait, you have a cool ritual though,
I know about just relaxing,
kind of de-stressing,
which I think is awesome.
- Thank you very much.
It's a ritual.
It's better if you have
a grill or a backyard.
- Okay.
- And right now I'm living in New York
so I haven't been able
to do it in a while.
But yeah, you know how, life is life
and we all kind of get
overwhelmed sometimes.
And one of the things I like to do is
you light a candle, set
a timer for 12 minutes,
get some paper, a pen, and
then just write for 12 minutes,
and you don't even think
about what you're writing.
- Oh!
- You don't even read it back.
And then at 12 minutes you stop the timer
and then you set the thing on fire.
- This sounds awesome.
- It's really great.
And there's just
something really wonderful
about taking all the stuff
that was making you so kind of worked up
and off your center and destabilized
that you could probably scream.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And watching it just turn into ash
and like turn into nothing.
It's really powerful.
- I love that, I love the,
you know, it turning into ashes thing.
That's nice.
- Yeah, it is.
- All right.
Well, we're both gonna be...
- We're complicated
creatures, aren't we all?
- We are.
- By the way, Alexis,
that was a beautiful story about your mom.
Thank you for sharing.
- [Kelly] I know.
- [Anne] Thank you.
- I know and she looks
so beautiful today too.
- I mean, yeah. Look at our audience.
(audience clapping)
- So we're both turning 40 this year.
- We are both turning 40.
- I'm excited.
- [Anne] Congratulations!
- Congratulations.
Well, I think it's,
I know a lot of women in the
industry get weird about age.
I love it.
I feel like life gets, I don't know
exponentially better, like every year.
- I get more comfortable every year
and I get more grateful.
And that, I feel like staying
grateful is getting easier.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think, I don't know,
I think that some times
a little bit of it is,
I've always had friends.
I mean, you're probably the same way
being in the music industry.
You've had the opportunity to learn
from so many people that came before.
So I've always had friends
from older generations.
And so for me, aging never
seemed like a big deal
because I've always
had friends those ages.
- Yeah.
- And, but I have lost,
a few friends have shifted,
and I realize that I'm
over the halfway point.
If I go at the same point as them.
- Yeah.
- So the way I'm holding it is like,
"Oh yeah, you're turning 40.
"You might be closer to the
end than the beginning."
Just get to the good stuff.
- Yeah.
- Get to the good stuff
because you don't know.
- I love that!
- And like, come on.
(audience clapping)
- I mean, the world is
the world right now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So if you have the
opportunity to choose joy,
then I think we are obliged
to take it, frankly.
- Absolutely, I love also
that you said shifted,
because I always think it's weird
how people are always like,
you know, friends, we do come,
there are seasons for some
relationships in our lives.
And I think that that's
important that that's okay.
So I like that you said shifted though.
That was really good.
- Yeah, I don't like to
say that they're lost
and by the way I don't usually talk
about this stuff personally.
I think I'm turning red.
You're really good at what you do.
- Oh!
- But no, I like
I like shifted because I don't...
- It's nice.
- I think it's softer and
to me it feels more honest.
- Yeah, absolutely, and it's cool.
- Because this might not,
that might not be the end of the story.
We don't actually know.
- That's what I mean, there's seasons.
That's what I...
- Yeah.
- People do come and go.
And I think that that's
something I learned.
Actually, it's funny 'cause you did say,
'cause I'm from the music industry,
and just in the industry in general,
I think everybody,
there are literally so many
different types of ages.
Like there's so many
generations in what we do
like especially on tour.
So it's awesome.
I think you learn from all
of those different people
and I think that people
come and go and it's nice.
- Yeah.
- And you can still be
friends with those people
but it's just like a different season.
Anyway.
- [Anne] Yeah.
- I didn't even mean to go there.
(Anne giggles)
- So you did that to me.
(audience clapping)
- So speaking of celebration,
so I hear that you have a
special way of eating cupcakes.
- I do.
- And I love cupcakes,
So I thought I would take
this opportunity selfishly
to bring cupcakes out.
- Yes!
- And I wanna see your way.
- Okay.
- Is this mine, thank you, Justin!
Oh, I'm gonna be fancy!
- So, I did not...
- Okay, okay.
- I like red velvet.
- Thank you very much, thank you.
- Wait, what was yours?
I'm red velvet.
- I just got, well,
I'm kind of feeling.
I've been in a rainbow mood.
- Oh, I like it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, rainbow sprinkles?
- Yeah I just feel like we should all
keep saying gay in Florida.
So we should wear as
much rainbow as possible.
(audience cheering)
- While that idiocy is being debated.
- So I wanna know,
we're gonna stop for some commercials,
but I wanna know how you eat a cupcake
'cause I hear you eat one differently
and I wanna learn Obi Wan.
- Okay so I didn't realize
that this was that unusual
until I was at my friend's
Steph's 40th birthday.
Okay and it got omicron.
So we couldn't have a cake.
So we did cupcakes.
We got omicron.
And so I took my cupcake
and I sat there and we
were having a conversation
and I did this thing and
it stopped the party.
Now I have stopped parties before
but never for a good reason.
And this was a good way to stop a party.
So you take the top.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Anne] And you pull it
apart and then you flip it.
- You like a like whoopie
pie, almost like you make it.
- And then you have a sandwich
and you don't get frosting up your nose.
(audience clapping)
- I'm gonna be honest with you.
I didn't know.
I never seen anyone do this
but it reminds me like
of how whoopie pies are.
- I should have toasted
you before I took a bite.
Sorry about that.
- I don't even know who
allowed to for COVID reason.
- So it's probably better.
- Ding, air ding.
- It would be no and it's nicer too.
'Cause then you've get
like the sandwich effect.
- And then you can just kind, and then
it like feels more casual,
more like an hor d'oeuvres
which all I just wanna make
all desserts feel casual
so we can eat more of them.
'Cause they're so good.
- I love this and I'm stealing it.
(audience cheering)
- Now let's have a look at
her new Apple TV plus series.
"wecrashed".
The new series, it's the story
of WeWork, the communal office space.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
I started watching it just
'cause I'm a fan of y'all.
I didn't actually know
it was a real thing.
So then I went down, I
was like, this is amazing.
This should be, I literally
was like, this should be like
is this a real story?
And I Googled and I found
out it was so is this amazing to like do
or is it hard to play like real people?
Do you ever feel extra pressure on that?
- Well, I didn't know
anything about WeWork either.
- Oh, okay, me either.
- Yeah so I kind of
like you read the pilot
and then Googled it and then I wound
up speaking to a lot of
people about the characters.
But just get back to your question.
I don't think it should
make such a difference
to play someone real someone living,
but it does at the end of the
day, I think, I think it does.
I felt a real responsibility to be fair.
- Yeah.
- You know, especially
because like I said,
I read the articles that had been written
and then I talked to people
that knew my character
and the truth was a lot more complicated
and the word that kept coming up about her
which surprised me based
on what I had read was she was so sweet.
- Yeah.
- She was so sweet and I thought,
oh, that's very interesting.
And I wonder if I can
do in that perform if
if I can give a performance
that would allow for all of it
that would allow for the
mistakes and would allow
for the parts of her
that are likely admirable
because that's what a human being is.
I mean, we we're creatures
that make mistakes
but there's also parts of us
that work and that are great.
And we have good moments.
- And they're so captivating, persuasive.
There's a lot of admirable
qualities and both of,
I love their relationship
but before we get too deep, I've seen it.
You maybe haven't so maybe
tell them a little bit
about what it's about
if people don't know.
- Sure, sure, sure.
So "wecrashed" is a story
of WeWork, which was a
started out as a communal
co-working space.
- Which is a cool idea.
- It was a cool idea.
It was look, if they had been able
if they had been ready to
practice what they preached
would've been a very different series
and a very different story.
- Yeah.
- So, so anyway, so it's
the story of the rise
and fall of this company
as told through the lens
of two of the co-founders
Rebekah Neumann and yeah.
Rebekah Paltrow Neumann and Adam Neumann.
- Yeah, it's interesting too,
and I don't know if you felt
this, but I was watching
and I was telling my executive
producer this morning
I was like, oh my gosh.
So I got lost and I kept it's
this is one of those shows
you're gonna binge watch
'cause you can't just watch one.
It's like chips.
And so you can't just eat one.
And like, so I kept watching it
because I was honestly, really--
- You could just watch one chip
Like that's enough for me.
- Exactly.
- That's fine.
I'm satisfied.
- Girl, your mouth to God's ear,
but they're just so good and salty.
No, but it, it was hard
to stop because I did,
I was captivated by the story,
but I was also captivated
by their love and support of
each other and it's a very
intense, y'all play
very intense characters.
- [Anne] Yeah.
- And I just really appreciated
the relationship honestly.
And I haven't watched
the entire thing yet.
I'm almost done, but I,
'cause I had to sleep.
I was like, I had like tape on my eyelids
but I was, I was just, so engaged with it.
And I thought this story was so well done.
So why did you wanna do it?
Why, what captivated you?
- Well, it's this moment
that we're all living in
and I don't know exactly what it is
and it's a much larger conversation
about what it is that
we're all going through
that we really need
something to believe in.
'Cause we all do, we all need
we're all hoping that a unicorn is real.
We're all hoping that, you know
there's going to be kind
of a magic wand wave
and we're gonna get a happy ending.
And so we keep these stories
keep appealing to us.
And I do believe that look
there's a way to do this where
like they're villains and
they're bad from the beginning.
And I get that, but I also
think there's a version
of it where that's probably a
little bit more true, which is
that most people mean the
things that they say they intend
for them to be true.
Whether or not that person
is living the same reality
as everyone else is up for debate.
- Yeah.
- And whether or not we would've noticed
if that thing had eventually
come true that whole fake it
until you make it thing.
We notice when it doesn't come true.
We notice when somebody didn't make it.
- Yeah.
- But we don't always notice when they do.
So what is it about that
combination of us needing
to believe in something and
be willing to go on that ride
with the people who are willing to fake it
till they make it.
And how far are they willing to take it?
I just wrote a song on Kelly Clarkson.
(laughing)
- I will sing it.
You sing very well.
Also your lipstick battle was--
- [Anne] That's very
generous coming from you.
- You sing so well.
- Okay thank you.
- [Kelly] Whatever.
- Whatever.
- So wait, so we thought it would be
a fun thing to do a musical game.
Are you cool with that?
- I am.
(audience cheering)
- Well after the break Anne and I play
a friendly but intense game.
Be sure, 'cause I'm very competitive.
Be sure to watch "wecrashed"
streaming every Friday
on Apple TV plus we'll
be right back y'all.